most entrepreneurs that I know have a
collection of quotes that they keep and
then look to for inspiration for
guidance and for wisdom they're helpful
reminders of the light that we want to
lead and give us direction and guidance
and courage when we're uncertain or
we're afraid so today I'm going to share
with you the top 10 quotes that every
entrepreneur should live by number 10
trip Hawkins from Electronic Arts one
quality of entrepreneurship is just
persistence not giving up because you
have roadblocks and also not giving in
because other people tell you that
you're nuts you are nuts and you should
be proud of it stick with what you
believe in number nine is a door sharp
from the Four Seasons Hotel whatever you
do don't ever use a crutch and don't
ever think of having an excuse for not
having said yeah I did my best
number eight Donald Trump I was
relentless even in the face of total
lack of encouragement because much more
often than you'd think
here persistence is the difference
between success and failure number seven
Chris Gardner from Gardner richen
company find something that you love
something that gets you so excited you
can't wait to gather bed in the morning
forget about money be happy number six
Tony Robbins for changes to be of any
true value they've got to be lasting and
consistent any time you sincerely want
to make a change the first thing you
must do is to raise your standards if
you don't set a baseline standard for
what you'll accept in life you'll find
it's easy to slip into behaviors and
attitudes or quality of life that's far
below what you deserve whatever happens
take responsibility the only thing
that's keeping you from getting what you
want is a story you keep telling
yourself number five Anita Roddick from
the body shop whatever you do be
different that's the advice my mother
gave me and I can't think a better
advice for an entrepreneur
if you're different you will stand out
number four
Ted Turner all my life people have said
that I wasn't going to make it
you can never quit winners never quit
and quitters never win number three Tony
Robbins a real decision is measured by
the fact that you've taken a new action
if there's no action you haven't truly
decided the most important thing you
could do to achieve your goals is to
make sure that as soon as you set them
you immediately begin to create momentum
the most important rules that I ever
adopted to help me in achieving my goals
were those I learned from a very
successful man who taught me the first
write down the goal and then to never
leave the sight of setting a goal
without first taking some form of
positive action towards its attainment
number two Oprah Winfrey what I know for
sure is that if you want to have success
you can't make success your goal the key
is not to worry about being successful
but to instead work towards being
significant and the success will
naturally follow if you do work that you
love and work that fulfills you the rest
will come and I truly believe that the
reason I've been able to be so
financially successful is because my
focus has never ever for one minute been
money would you do your job and not be
paid for I would do this job and take on
a second job just to make ends meet if
nobody paid me that's how you know
you're doing the right thing
number one Steve Jobs from apple
believed that things will work out
somehow follow your intuition and
curiosity trust your heart even when it
leads you off the well-worn path you
have to trust that the dots will somehow
connect in your future the only way to
do great work is to love what you do if
you haven't found it yet keep looking
don't settle as with all matters of the
heart you'll know when you find it have
the courage to follow your heart and
intuition they somehow already know what
you truly want to become everything else
is
in there so those are the top ten I hope
my favorite quotes help inspire you help
make you believe in yourself more and
I'd love to hear what your favorite
famous entrepreneur quotes are leave
them in the comments below I'll check
them out thank you guys so much for
watching believe and I'll see you soon
hi every Cal English here with mermaid
junkie TV are you on evans newsletter
subscription if not you should be I read
every single one and you should too ciao
you